- Hello, Believe Nation, it's Evan,
and, as you know, probably by now,
I've written a book called Your One Word.
It's all about helpin' you find
the one core value that you have
and then bring it to your
life and to your business
so you can create something that has
much more meaning, more intension,
more value and more awesomeness.
And so, I finally created a new series
to try to share some of the one words
of successful entrepreneurs
that we look up to.
The first video in this
series was on Oprah Winfrey.
Her one word was love,
and I want to continue the
series today with will.i.am.
- If you had to think of one word
that's most important to
you or that sums you up
or that would be kind
of like a little beacon.
- Will.
Not in the egotistical way, either.
Just the will.
And not the thing you
write before you die.
The will, to have will, determination,
to have strength, courage, will.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this clip?
Also I'm really curious to
know what is your one word?
If you've figured it out,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, guys, I'll see ya soon.